are you finding it difficult
to outline support and resistance levels?
well, I'm about to show you the simplest way
to effectively Mark up these zones
so that you could trade off of them.
let's take a look.
so if you're ever analyzing a typical price chart
and you're just confused
where the support and resistance levels
should be outlined,
why don't you try changing it from a candlestick chart
to a line chart?
this will give you a better representation
of where Price has been reacting with
in the past.
you could just easily identify
where the lines have been rejecting with.
and this just gives you exactly
where the candles have been rejecting away from.
so we can see that we do have a rejection point here.
we do have another zone up in here,
and then we have an extreme zone up in here.
and then when we switch back to the candlestick chart,
we can see that all of these zones
that we've outlined from the line chart
are very viable zones that we could now trade off of.
a line chart is much more visually pleasing,
especially for new traders
who want a more simplistic approach to the markets.
I would definitely advise you to look at a line chart
instead of a candlestick chart
when you're analyzing support and resistance levels.